what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host down Sathyan very pumped
to now be talking about acting and
directing we have favor and joining us
on the show hi Faye hi Allan nice to
meet you
thanks for coming on the program I know
how cool was it that we got to meet on
the flight from Vancouver oh yeah to San
Francisco yeah and get a long deep dive
into acting directing spirituality who's
super fun very interesting conversation
yeah the source putting people together
for such interesting reasons face
backgrounds great she's an actor and
director whose work focuses on telling
stories to effect positive change you
can find all of her links in the bye
below to her Instagram profile IMDB
profile as well as her most recent
appearance on Poehler on Netflix you
guys can find that link in the bio below
as well okay on the flight we were
talking so much about the nuances of
acting and directing an art in general
and what it can catalyze for other
people when they awaken to these
messages they are trying to convey so T
just about kind of your journey leading
up to the point of where you figured out
that you wanted to get involved and then
what really lights your fire in this
field I feel like when I got into acting
at the beginning it was more like
finding a place of Qarth artic release
so it was a very selfish reason but
regardless that opened up a whole
journey of self-discovery and and and
one thing really something I'm always
passionate about whether it's acting and
prior to that I've been modeling like
I've been modeling for 10 11 years was
that the connection I felt during
performance that something really frees
me and makes me feel very empowered and
I think with good storytelling that's
kind of what happens it connects people
and resonates and I think that's what
then the purpose is for me to become
good actor is to convey better stories
and
hopefully positively effects or awake
people to and and and also like when I
was watching shows the best shows
whether it's theater where movies really
taught me things and made me had that
big moment and it's I think that's
essentially what really excites me yeah
this is why I think we were resonating
so deeply on the plane because we both
saw it from the very macro level
perspective of what art can do to
inspire people and awaken them so okay
so then the career were winding back so
it was you're born in China born and
raised in China and tell around 18 or so
yeah okay and then made the move to come
to Canada when you BC for psychology so
UBC Forsyte that's right yes and then
the University British Columbia is
gorgeous I love that place and you
studied psych there it's awesome and
then you started picking up modeling
around that time yeah okay randomly got
into it yeah through a charity show in
school and then just start picking up as
like and then went travelling for it and
so I had two years kind of stopped
schooling and travelled more for
modeling and then I did like one
semester both traveling and doing four
classes online that burned me out and I
was like okay I better come back and
finish the school and then go back
traveling for modeling but that's when
my grandpa got really ill with dementia
and it made me realize oh well first of
all I have to give up traveling and
taking care of him but it's also made me
realize life is so short he only lived
once as far as I come I know
and so I better live for myself that's
where I was like always wanted to try
out acting so I'm gonna do it yeah Wow
sometimes it's really beautiful when we
look at things from a perspective of
maybe these things are not happening to
me in a way that harms me but rather
there have
for me and for our family to awaken us
to certain things and so yeah um for you
it was this fire under your butt that
you know you have fifty more years of
life to live and do you want to do what
you love every day yeah and live for
other people's expectation or for myself
and I think my upbringing was very much
about being a nice girl and pleasing and
a lot of fulfill my parents expectation
which I mean no complain it brought me
to beautiful places but at the same time
there part of myself that I've never
really embraced which was always
artistic but my parents always pushed me
towards more safe route of size or or
Commerce that's what a lot of Chinese
parents would feel safe about likewise
this goes into so many other cultures
around the world as well Armenian myself
as well was very heavy towards law or
doctor or whatever the most could
reasonably I mean I mean art doesn't
make stable money and it's a really
risky career like my family none of them
are artists so it's hard to imagine that
as a career path I didn't even imagine
myself being able to do it now full-time
but I think that's when you align your
purpose with your passion and the hard
work actually can't happen it's not easy
but it do it does happen yeah and
there's a there's the social fabric
redesign that we're going through
hopefully where it is more conducive for
people to express themselves in the arts
and that it is people able to become
that unique instrument that they want to
play in this big symphony that's
unfolding that is our consciousness
evolution that's happening and that
being so important there's been so many
examples in the past
of Lorenzo de Medici in Florence doing
things like patronymic Colangelo da
Vinci Botticelli's in abling the Italian
Renaissance there is other examples like
even prior to any of the agrarian days
but going even back up tens of thousands
hundred thousands plus years ago there
is just periods of time of just play you
just hunt gather and play and that made
me story tell that maybe through acting
singing dancing music of all sorts and
that's such a core aspect of creativity
and artists play yeah and it creates the
software of how we think in our values
and moral compass in a lot of ways like
if you think about the example that we
learn how to conduct ourselves in school
we don't really teach that we teach
sighs and a lot of practical stuff but
how you learn about the nuances of
social interaction it's a lot from
watching either around us or film and
television so yeah
storytelling is the way to one one of
the main facet I think to to contribute
to the social programming or like
software programming yeah our behaviors
yeah I like how you view it from a
perspective of kind of like programming
my behaviors and my spirituality my
awareness my consciousness with art and
with creativity at young ages with
social emotional intelligence at young
ages makes it so that were not kind of
just stuck in the rational thinking of
brain choking the heart style of life
that we see basically the economic
machinery of today doing that and
preventing this example with parents
preventing children from unleashing
their inner artist due to the pressures
of this machinery yeah yeah I want to
ask you about this endeavor of yours
with modeling and how it led you
to acting how did that transition happen
well in modeling it's very different
because modeling the actual life
performance part is all fragmented
because you get captured for that moment
or the 30 minutes you are 30 seconds you
are on the runway so it's a very short
time of performance but none of the less
is really really alive when you do it
well and and when I was entering the
industry that was like 10 11 years ago
there was a lot of racial prejudice
which was very fun to to have as a chip
on the shoulder to prove them wrong in a
way like everybody literally tells me
that they have one Asian model in the
agency and they don't need any more
because there's no demand or probably at
that time the working Asian model in
Canada it was like one or two that I
know of and a lot of shows I was in it's
like the only Asian so that was
interesting and I'm also short so it's
like two hardwired kind of like a bet
barrier that I had a lot of fun to prove
people that oh I guess do do this
because I'm extra professional I'm
really working hard and I have a lot of
fun personality so that's something I
learned through modeling is like Oh
everybody is beautiful or unique looking
one way or another but that's not what
defined your booking or your success you
could push that boundary by really
committing and bring a different
attitude and change your own game so I
wasn't further than I thought I would
and which to me is a very exciting
journey and I learned a ton and I broke
out of the comfort shell and through
traveling is just like so much I have to
learn about myself and how to
step into the discomfort and really grow
so yes yeah this is a another phenomenon
that's seen in the different countries
around the world with the different
demographics of people so given if your
specific skin color or religion or
whatever way you want to identify
yourself in those specific areas it may
be harder to pursue a specific form of
art based on that and so the sort of
like egalitarian view of treating people
equally in terms of based on their
performance based on their art based on
their spirit based on their actual
execution and creativity rather than
based on their religion or their skin
color or whatever so this is a very
interesting I think transitory period
that we're going through regarding that
as well as our consciousness evolves
towards seeing it more as a unity and
seeing people more based on what art
they actually express we you teach us of
what it means when you like model for
like 30 seconds you're saying and then
there's like in a sense you're doing
like acting during that 30 seconds
you're acting like a model yeah like
well when you are on the runway what
you're trying to portray is whatever
that collection the the designer usually
has a specific idea behind it and then
when you are on the runway it's your
work it's your job as a model to carry
that whether it's fierceness it's an
georgia knee like whatever concept do
they want to experience to carry that
out in on the runway and usually it's
like each look takes 30 seconds to like
maybe two minutes if it's super long one
so you get that very quick time to
really translate that and sometimes like
hundreds of people watching this show
has to feel it and it's actually quite a
adrenal and rush because you get that
one try and then it's so alive and when
you do well and you do feel it
and it's such a powerful freeing feeling
at least for me that was how what draws
me to runway and then in front of camera
same thing for that one moment was the
lens it's click and then that become an
image and it's a very fragmented
way you pose pose pose and then each
moment it could be a very different idea
that you are portraying but again for
editorial or creative terminology
modeling where you just portraying a
theme as well so it's a lot exploring
sexuality alai exploring female
empowerment yeah I myself find during
the time it was a lot to do with Oh
being fierce like face brand because my
bone structure and certain look that I
gave is a lot to do with like the
fierceness so that becomes some traits
that I never thought I would embrace
because I told you I was upbringing is
people-pleasing ever being over to lay
nice and a compromising but in modeling
actually brings out a different side of
me yeah well there's a lot there so one
of them is that there's a certain
there's certain the this this what
you're trying to represent with given
what the designer has made with the
clothing that they're aiming to display
is you you have to carry a specific
persona or personality with that yeah
albeit you may have had a you know
something happened earlier that day or a
family member or fell sick or whatever
it may be there may be so many other
components that you're kind of like
juggling at the same time but you have
to in that frame of time yeah be I mean
it's kind of like this we have our
hour-long conversation and you may be
thinking about so many other things in
me too
but we hat we're focused on our
conversation you have that you know
minute or so slot okay so what is it
like what is a specific clothing or that
requires fierceness and what's another
one that requires in drogyny like what
is that that's
you really depends on the designer but I
find right now like Cutrone is like a
lot of designers that are all exploring
androgyny kind of concept to wear a lot
of clothes are both female and male like
you you see women wear a lot of
oversized blazer I think right now we
are also in a different climate where
women are not always expected to be a
one way of sexy so it's exciting time
where you can be unique
like even modeling industry start
evolving like different sizes and shapes
and you can tattoo can have a very short
like different hair different gender and
be guity like it's exciting time so I
think that reflected with the time
change and and it really depends on the
the designer but there are artists too
so they're always exploring something
that reflects social change is is
optionality in makeup also oh yes having
this evolving element of like how the
makeup changes hair changes like you the
way you walk changes body shape changes
like how I think back in the day there
was a period of like sexy is more one
way now it's like diverse and more
acceptance to always of beings so I
think it's evolving yeah you use
beginning to give us all these different
nuances to acting or to modeling kind of
leads me into those are actually quite
similar nuances of acting yeah so the
Newlands of modeling you actually have a
lot to do with yeah acting yeah so what
was it like for you then to be like okay
I want to unleash even further towards
acting and how did you get that started
that was always in there like when I
when I was in high school I did do some
drama and a university on my side a
elective somewhere like film study like
art history or I joined like
clubs and did a shows so it's always
something I want to explore but I never
truly commit into exploring until facing
severe illness from my grandpa that I
was like a life short it was short so
let's get on it and that's where I find
I just I I went into it with the with
the expectation like not as a career I
still had a full-time job at the time
but I just wanted to do this for myself
for once and and then that evolved into
more and more passion developed as I'm
delving deeper into looking at to myself
so that I can use part of myself and how
to channel it for characters and then as
that evolved like my voice start
changing I used to talk very differently
and my behavior change how I view myself
and my sexuality everything starting and
spirituality comes in as well
also the whole journey become much more
than oh I want to do acting like I've
never thought about it oh I need to be
famous or make a lot of money no it's
just becoming a study of self and acting
always shifts so much like project to
projects I guess we well touch upon I
think like from filming polar to like
producing a leading lungs it's
completely different experience yes so
so much to learn and that's something
I'm really excited about too because you
can never learn enough there's always
something and I'm just hungry for
learning so that's really good
yeah yeah likewise and that whole show
so premise thon being hungry for
learning and also just a quick bit on
this before we move in I feel as though
sometimes this idea of portraying
ourselves whether it be modeling
or acting with a specific intent when
we're trying to convey something like
fierceness or sexuality or a drogyny or
whatever it may be given that small
frame yeah it kind of reminds me of the
way that we communicate this extended
phenotype of ours out into the world
where we're trying to we're trying to
sell ourselves on all of our social
profiles a very specific way mm-hmm and
so there's a little bit of both
yeah I get it but I also am trying to
get people to like yeah find it yeah and
be kind of cool with like you know
having a little like shin sometime more
like being like nah you know on the you
know just like be quirky dorky nerdy
geeky all fast like all different
aspects of yourself and I told you about
I was training clowning for the past two
years yes in clowning we talked about
masks and how I got into clowning was I
wanted to it I told the teacher I was
like I really need to just explore the
authentic like I want to know what they
who is fair like the most authentic
version of myself because honestly we
always play masks somewhere like we
always have a certain kind of identity
in all different situations so who is
real me especially after playing so many
characters I was like okay but what
what's me what's other people like why
am i able to do this choice or feel that
emotion and and so I went in with the
intention to really learn my authentic
self and my clown teacher end up saying
so what what do you think is authentic
why do you think all these other masks
is not you it could be you it's just
extension of you and then like yeah of
course there's rooted value thank you
now I think there's more authentic in
income
see in like what's your root what's you
deeply believe and won't compromise and
then cross situation that will always
guide you but then of course we are
always forced and shaped by
circumstances so we may choose different
things based on situation but there is
roots there yeah I'm so excited to also
talk about this from this you know you
heard me say a little bit ago this like
this extended phenotype or the way that
we share our our status in the hierarchy
out to the world whether it be travel or
whether it be through best version best
version of ourselves and so when you do
something like work with these like
acting coaches on these things like
clowning you you kind of you dive a
little bit deeper into what is
practicing exaggerating these different
personas laughing at it yeah so instead
of being controlled by this oh I have to
this identity that I have to live up to
or this ego that I'm wearing it's more
like honestly my truth is I'm aware this
is a ego that I'm wearing right now and
I'm hahahaha and I can extend it and
make it really funny and then everybody
can identify with it because yeah
everybody wears that at one point or
another so then I become a release and
they become a lesson so people feel it's
okay to release this certain kind of
image or to wear another image that is
completely different I love that so it's
like you know if we were to play right
now and we were to say like haha you are
Allen and you have this show where you
sit here in the chair and ask people all
these questions and you know you kind of
like make fun of yourself you're trying
to get to the ultimate nature of reality
and that's all that you care about and
so you're mister king of the ultimate
nature of reality you know and so that
way we're just poking fun and over
exaggerating yeah it holds no power over
you they become not such a eco thing
that you had to hold downside to cuz I
look at me I'm just like so joyous to
right now just like cuz cuz it's
hilarious doing this nah it's super fun
and that a miss Fei Ren who's all about
acting and modeling and yeah and
directing and has all these great shows
going on for her and she knows that that
she has all these nuances to activate
and to be successful pretend you know
what I'm talking about
yeah yeah it's it's such a beautiful
journey with clownin because I really
learned like I really learned to to not
taking myself too seriously and to
develop that joy and to play and I think
with a lot of acting training certain
different school of thought I got a
little bit too dark and too serious and
when you lose the joy as shows in your
work I become a little bit too intense
and it really carries it into my body
that I was telling you that yes
let's explore this one yeah I actually
brought me to a journey of healing
myself because I I wasn't aware there's
an emotional body and emotion like
through imagination of all the character
work my emotional body actually going
through the trauma Jude let's break this
down with the actual story so this is
food let's do the lungs let's do the
lungs example yeah okay so you were
directing and of producing I'm producing
and leading because there was another
director yes you're producing and
leading in lungs yeah and you were
teaching me that this is very
interesting because it's not the set
design does not have lights it does not
have proper I don't come like McMillan
he is like very specific on no set
design no light no seam changes like
that is indicated through anything so
and no miming so
everything is through relationship and
dialogue but it was crystal clear for
the audience and its time-lapse of the
whole lifetime from the two-person fall
in love all the way until the death so
there's a lot here because it requires
the story like you said is the two
person I'm falling in love until death
but also that in preparation for all of
these performances so you have you know
you have these performances in life
theater settings and you're doing this
over and over again these at times yeah
and you have to when you come in you
have to no matter what happened that day
you have to calibrate you're performing
with your partner that you're performing
with so you have to do these deeply
spiritual exercises of connecting to
them through their eyes and doing that
to grow yourself in that relation yeah
we touched upon like you are mentioning
eye contact as a spiritual exercise but
as I was mentioning it's a very common
exercising acting and a lot of people in
normal life week uh civilian civilians
they're not comfortable with just like
eye contact for extensive length of
period but in acting because well I have
to portray this lifetime story love
story with this actor who is just my
coworker and friend in real life to
portray that kind of chemistry onstage
we have to build connections and whether
it's through endowing substituting or
like me imagine him as some other people
that would referencing to the story or
through just simply using eye contact to
build that connection it's it's a
process like two hours before the show
usually we would have like warm-ups and
that's exactly and then that's like an
athlete a lot of people compare acting
especially theater acting with athletes
because it is a craft and it is very
physical and
they do have some studies shows that the
actors where they go through adrenaline
wise it's the same amount during acting
it's same amount when their encounter a
car accident it's a lot of adrenaline
rush and it's a lot of pressure because
you're a performing live you kind of
can't fail and you have three months
prior to really exercise everything or
we had three months prior to to really
rehearse but still there are so much
elements that could go wrong and you
have to trust the process and so all you
can do is preparation and do as much as
you can and then you just let go of the
work and yeah it'd be be be it'll be
that channel so but you prepare your
channel through those two hours of prep
before the shows and then okay now this
is where we're you are starting to
explain this to us so then you take on
the actual spirit of the character in
the play itself yeah well I wouldn't
explain it like for example I would have
already taken on the character for a
while for the two hours all my muscle
memories from months of rehearsal is
there so me is not really as Fae it's
it's my friend during the time said my
speech rhythm everything is quite off
compared to normal thing so they know
that it's the character after they saw
the show they were like oh that's why
Faye is acting weird because she is
carrying on the character but it's more
it's like concentrated during the show
and then because the show has so much
like we delve into heavy topic of like
miscarriage like betrayal and then like
there's a lot of love and loss you go
through those roller coasters and you
don't really heal from it so at the end
of the each night my body is really felt
like being hit by a truck like it was
literally in paying
over the place so for me become very
very important to find a place where I
can release it because you took on
miscarriage you took on betrayal you
took on three imaginations
there were these emotional response
right there trying to convince you're
trying to sell the audience on the story
yeah so you have to be really good at
yeah and and and so your body can't
distinguish whether it happened or not
all it had is like if that's like it
went through a lot and and that's where
your stamina is actor has to be really
good because you carry it night after
night and then you have to be okay and
functional as a human being you can't be
like okay I'm gonna use this part of my
trauma and but no it's that part of
trauma only on stage existed for five
minutes and then you have to heal and
move on so how you can be okay with it
that's become where crafted cake kicks
in like it's not just instinctually like
MA
vomited out it's like you have to
reproduce it night after night to some
extent it can vary in performance but
the given circumstances force you to
react to this specific trauma right so
so your body like as a actor I think a
lot of studios doesn't really teach you
about they teach us how to get into the
acting getting into the character but
not so much about how to get out that
become my journey the past year to try
to figure out how do I get out safely
how do I release this so then I don't
need to have this affecting my real life
and I can have a functioning body like I
get to a place I was so burned out last
year I was like paying like just tension
in the muscles like nothing can really
work and I can't sleep I can't breathe
well like it start affecting my life and
my work like everything so so there has
to be some sort of a process for actors
to do things like take
what they've been channeling on the set
through the communication of the
performance but then be able to somehow
energetically kind of like really
release it and that's what my clown
teacher taught really well it's like
each time when we put on a mask there's
a ritual like okay now it's the mask on
and then he was really really particular
about you come off the performance you
take off the mask and go back to your
ringmaster and that's something I find
it's a really good like a diligent thing
you have to do as actor like you have to
take off the the the character at the
end of the night as at the best possible
way I love your focus on ritual it's a
ritual to put on the mask it's a ritual
to take off the mask or routine right
routine yeah so for the lungs it's so
because of the over the year trying to
find a ways of healing that I I
collected some different ways but one of
them is dancing turned out to be really
good
yeah and I've I've had a talks with
different people healing from like
deeper grief or trauma that actively
dancing to happy things and really
having a diaphragm laugh like those deep
giggle really helps because it brings
you into that childlike quality where
it's full of joy and innocence and love
and and do you you reprogram your body
into like a joist ad instead of always
stuck in kind of heavy energy and
through dance like my column teacher
also said this like he said animals when
they are in shock and they freeze and
then after there they know they are safe
they kind of like like release that
right but we as human when we are like
experiencing something in life right now
in modern days we don't go out and
release it consciously
we like dwell and rule
and I'm just like sit in it and it's
stuck in your body start eating and
distracting ourselves a social media
yeah or yeah you can physically hack
yeah the energetic release yeah that's
why a lot of people choose to exercise
when they feel stress it's actually
exercise well exercise is a great way
but I I'm not into gym so for me it's
like silly dance yeah yeah and then and
then I can meditate make yourself laugh
yeah yeah so that childlike state of
love innocence purity tell us the story
of after you do this performance you
have this specific segment in there that
ends up awakening one of the audience
members that had an instant similar
instance with his girlfriend yeah well
that's something I find it's quite
common with good stories like this story
there was moment of dealing with grief
very differently so my character went
through miscarriage and then my partner
like my boyfriend in the play wasn't
giving me enough space and he made it
mostly about himself or trying to get
emotional reassurance when I'm depressed
and kind of closed off and my character
was just asking for holding the space
where he was trying to guilt trip me and
eventually cheated on me so that's
that's the storyline but to have that in
the play and one of my friend he came to
watch the show and had a realization of
why his ex and him didn't work out after
the postpartum depression he finally
understood what she was asking him off
because she couldn't articulate maybe or
she wasn't able to get through him about
she just needed him to be a bigger
person to hold the space for her instead
of telling her what to do and tried to
fix it all the time and so all she
needed was was for him to hold a space
but of course is grieving for everybody
and shifts for everybody right so like
it's the how this kind of couple
communication was failing on stage
awakens or shows the other person oh I
understand my life like what happened it
maybe not do that again
Wow yeah I love that story so the
combination of really good story with
really good acting can trigger people to
realize some of their past and the way
that they may have can see it from a new
lens that shows them it more clearly
yeah and integrates some of the
awakening states within them through
being a guest at an art performance
that's why I think theater is so
important because you actually feel that
energy of the actor you really feel it
I rarely well with movies and things of
that I do cry but it's very rare but
with the theatre if it's good usually so
impactful because you really see and
witness a person going through things
and you really care about them with good
acting like good writing you start
really going the journey with the actor
and that everybody in the black seats
like audience DC is usually dark you
really can project yourself onto them
and learning through that journey so I
think that's a really powerful form of
art though
I have too bad we don't we don't really
not many cities still make them living
like have a good theatre support yeah
that circles us to the importance of the
arts and humanities and unleashing that
into the world yeah okay also this is
quite different from something like a
Netflix produced show like Poehler so
with lungs you're doing well how many
performances was it over how long of a
period
we did a eleven over three weeks eleven
over three weeks and then these are very
like ticket sales at theaters and then
you guys try and raise monies to be able
to do more art and performance and
theater versus these like big-budget
Netflix shows that have like people
flying from around the world into you
guys we're on-site in was it Montreal or
Toronto Toronto Toronto on-site in
Toronto and like you're like filming for
four months just filming four months
with like actual really high quality
cameras and like there's gonna be so
much post-production that happens this
is a completely different animal yeah
yeah we're this one like a Netflix one
it feels like I'm a little little screw
on a big machine we're on the lungs is
literally two actor so two person play
with like four producing partners so
it's like get on it yes and you're
nobody can fail everybody has to be
there and really show up otherwise it's
just extremely challenging we're the
other way is like hundreds of people on
it but with that one interestingly it
was a beautiful learning experience as
well of course there's ego start kicking
in it's like whoa this is Hollywood and
all these famous people I get to talk to
and befriend with and it's a different
challenge for artistic concentration I
think and and the set is really a lot of
shifts happening on the set all the time
with film acting I find it's different
from theatre it's like my experience you
live through the whole whole thing in
that two hours we're an hour and a half
we're on set is like the scene was all
not chronological and it's chopped up
into
this is very small pieces so is it like
a shortage to stub you know a minute
scene or like a couple minutes scene and
that sometimes the end of the movie can
Bieber middle the movie can be being
done at the beginning of the timeframe
it's always chopped up so it depends on
the location so the beginning of the
movie we shot like three months after we
wrapped because we have to wait for the
weather to become summer yeah and but
then we have to know what's the before
moment and what has happened so far yeah
so I think that's something and also
like there's so many people on set we
were shooting a lot on locations there's
a lot of things that just very
distracting so to to be able to focus
and to deliver the work when the time is
up or or when it's your time that's
that's kind of a big challenge I learned
and to to to understand that I learned a
lot from working with these amazing
actors who are famous already and they
they have no ego and I'm just like oh
that's refreshing because they were just
passionate about work and they weren't
like playing hierarchies and yeah like
oh I have way bigger trailers or take me
seriously they're just like they're just
so down to earth
excellent I love hearing that yeah
that's great so it's a very different
from what I heard about Hollywood and
yes and everybody is deeply passionate
and experienced so that was a really
beautiful experience to learn I also
encountered like my own ego in terms of
like oh I don't think I deserve to be
there so my insecurities start popping
out and and to overcome that and not
make it about me make it about the
character of where my character has to
be super confident so it's it's an
interesting thing to play to bring into
the character where maybe deeply deep
down she isn't that confident but the
more insecure she felt she she more
still have to prove herself
and that's usually the case in real life
too I'm happy that you shared with us
that there are aspects of Hollywood that
are in the more ego less for the art for
the inspiration side of things because
we have a very one way usually meme that
comes from a Hollywood which is ego
filled conspicuous consumption filled so
it's good it's good to hear that side of
things and hopefully we can as we awaken
we catalyze more of that good side the
benevolent side of it for the arts for
the inspiration not for the ego yeah for
a good artist it's usually like you have
to have some level of ego death and and
so if you look at all these Hollywood
star when they are doing interviews a
lot of them are very grounded and they
are saying really important things that
are social cautious and really focus on
craft I think it's how we social package
them because like their scandals and all
these little stories popping out which
is not necessarily them it's maybe
people projecting on it that happens or
or if yeah there will be negative story
but that's kind of in every industry
right there will be negative stereotypes
by a few individual that really pops out
and give that impression of how
Hollywood is but I think wherever the
good artists like good artists and
everything they well be they have to be
you know a certain level decent human
and able to take that ego suits out part
of that also speaks to me about how if
we can figure out which people in
Hollywood which people in Silicon Valley
that run the biggest companies here or
the ones that run the the billionaires
of the world are the ones that are
leading countries of the world if we can
figure out which ones have the deepest
states of actual true
ego loss and true feelings of
interconnectedness with other humans and
the environment that will in a sense if
you take like the biometric state of
Jeff Bezos and take the biometric state
of the Dalai Lama and you try and
compare those two there they're the
state of their EGF MRI the state of
their EKG their heart the state of their
microbiome like what do they actually
what is their auric energy expressing on
a moment-to-moment basis that can
actually help so much with Hollywood
being able to tell who's got it for the
ego and for the materialism who's in it
for the actual acting and inspiration of
other people and usually we can tell
without all these like sighs it would be
interesting to study I have yours but I
think it's you usually get a pretty good
handle just by interacting with but then
it's also subjective which is a problem
albeit you and I can have fun with it
subjectively and that's really great
when you and I say that oh this person
had more ego acting this one has less
right but then when we can objectively
measure with biometrics I can basically
share raw data with the rest of the
world and say that hey this is the raw
data this is not FEA now and talking
about how we feel about someone this is
raw data that does not lie and this has
been proven longitudinally five weeks
measuring every single day this person's
biometric state of their consciousness
so I think that whole aspect of of
things is gonna be this actually leads
me into the next point which is about
spiritual awakening in general because
the you basically in the last I think a
year or so have been going through more
and more awakening yourself and that
immediately started butterflying effect
for you into your family into your
friends so it was kind of like in a
sense it's no longer as easy for a
friend to just come and kind of like
monopolize on your time and just kind of
as people sometimes say they empirically
try and draw as much energy
out to kind of fill their themselves but
rather you know you're not you're not
willing to do that as much you're
willing to focus and more on trying to
make a big picture splash to thousands
or even hundreds of thousands hopefully
if people in the world through what you
do instead of just that one-on-one
exchange or your parents in the sense of
this happens to me it happens to all of
us as we awaken we no longer react to
the ways that we get triggered by our
families so all of a sudden your family
is sitting there and they're just you
know sometimes they're just yelling or
they're just being negative for you know
three minutes straight on just chewing
you up for something and then you just
sit there and you're just looking at
them with a love and you just don't say
anything and they go why you what do you
and all of a sudden they sometimes they
started like crying to themselves just
because you're their present with them
in a state of unconditional love teach
us about your stories with Awakening and
how it's effective family friends I so
my personal journey I feel I feel like
it was quite lucky because I have a
group of really beautiful people around
me that are awakening at the same time I
think we just positively affecting each
other and constantly sharing our journey
together and and really started a
meditation when I was filming polar
because after filming I was just in a
different time zone were filming to 4:00
a.m. and then I have to sleep at a odd
hours and I just started meditating to
sleep and that opened a different portal
eventually to like oh I can actually try
to meditate to raise myself into a
different more mindful way of thinking
and and then like so so many different
things
going back to with acting some of the
character emotional body I start to have
issues so I start manifesting illness
that that no specialist can't explain or
they were all it shows that you're fine
but I'm experiencing pain and they were
like oh then that must be like
psychological and da da da and so I was
forced to be like okay so now there's no
medicine no specialist can help me so
what can I do and I went into this I had
a really beautiful acupuncture nest to
help me to heal and it was dealing with
just acupuncture and guided meditation
but dealing with emotionally and
psychologically channeling like positive
light into different part of my body and
really breathe through it and now of
course I also had a really amazing
therapist it really helped me to uproot
some of my past that formed certain
negative pattern that developed a lot of
victim thinking or a very self
sabotaging way of talking and that to
build that awareness and then start to
accept it
oh that's part of me from before and
maybe no longer serving me and now I
have to like now I know better I have to
choose a different way that is more
positive really helped me so it's like a
handy hint from both psychologists and
also these holistic treatments like
healing and with those things happening
I start become very aware of my energy
just like in terms of my body start very
and to with so one of my one of my
psychologists used to tell me that oh
you have to connect your rational brain
with your gut feeling or intuition I'm
like
but how yeah so yeah past year I felt
like I developed developed a pretty good
into listening to my gut feelings so or
listening to my body in general so if I
have hanging out with certain people
that before I would afterwards go back
and have a headache or something and I
would ignore it and thinking that's
something wrong with my body now I would
be reflecting was that too much energy
consuming what's the dynamic in that
relationship made me man
maybe my body is sending me some kind of
signal absolutely and it was really
interesting how since this summer
until now I was like oh there are
certain situation or certain people that
after the Hangout I would have headaches
I would have all these physical symptoms
that was really the moment I did a
meditation clear out negative energy or
recharging with meditation trying to
imagine Lights into my body that I'm
funny
so I don't need Advil don't need any
kind of not seeking anyway it just
energetically I was leaking so now I'm
thinking more in those terms and really
helped me to guide who I choose to be
around and what kind of job I would have
choose to do and I think that's what I
essentially think it's mind with body in
tune together so my MA and my body
telling me something and in my my mind
it's like okay analyze realizing maybe
this is the case and then did a few try
on her and that's where I become more
into and then with the friends and
family it's like my family because
before I would be more of the fixer of
the home so I always deal with their
issues always have this codependent
relationship where I feel like a martyr
I felt like self-worth goes up if I can
fix them in some way but then that just
perpetually disempowered them to solve
their own issue and it build a really
different kind of toxic in some way
relationship
I get burned out as well so now I'm like
learning that okay I can't set
boundaries with my family and tell them
by the way it's not okay to just dump it
on especially when I'm not well so now
they would still ask for help but was
the mindfulness they would be like how
are you doing we don't want to bother
you with this but we're kind of
experiencing this but because I have so
many tools now that you know how to deal
with situation I would be offering the
tools but without being feeling like I
have to really fix it for them so it's
like learn to detach with love but also
just just know that it's not my
responsibility and then they have to
step up
yeah so in turn that they are and also
they see positive shifting me so
whatever I'm telling them I'm no longer
just like oh do this do that it's more
like I attracted them to trying to
experience what I'm experiencing so
they're like oh she's been always
meditating around us and it seems like
she's doing well before they would talk
well I'm meditating but now they aren't
I oh she's meditating okay well I'll
just let her be and then they would be
quiet but then they at the same time I
think it's affected by it yeah because
of consciousness yeah and so that was a
beautiful thing to see like okay they
are shifting and there were so many
beautiful things that I start
discovering with my family there's a new
relationship built more deep dialogue
with emotional exchange with my father
we start expressing like my parents has
never said I love you it's just not my
family culture I've heard this before
yeah so it's like whereas my mom and I
are saying it to each other all the time
yeah but then recently like my parents
will just say things they use action and
they use food to express love so I never
doubted their love surgery there's all
their ways expression yeah but they
never said those words but now they're
learning new love language
because of it because of all the work
and the communication so now my parents
they're saying I love you which is you
and my age Wow started from probably
last month yeah yeah whoa those are huge
shifts
those are huge huge shift afford them
they never expressed today in their life
to start being comfortable to express it
and for me to express back that they
feel loved and they they start doing
things differently and reacting to their
life choice differently so I was really
beautiful to see wow there's a couple
things here one of them is that I was
just having a call with a close friend
of mine last night who continues to pile
on the importance of his business and
he's sacrificing his well-being while
he's doing that and it's so interesting
talking to entrepreneurs artists
different types of creative people that
are trying to build the next world build
future and in the process of trying to
bring their unique gifts into the world
play their unique instrument to the
symphony they put their wellness on the
back seat thinking that by doing so they
can focus more on their business to
creativity it cetera but really if you
up your time on your wellness if you
stop the smoking of the cigarettes stop
the drinking of the soda stop drinking
alcohol exercise more sleep better all
these types of basic basic things all of
a sudden your productivity and your
focus and your ideas on where you need
to be passing your time every single day
will make it so that your business and
your creative all that stuff actually
becomes even more efficient than when
you were trying to sleep only three
hours a night or China etc so that point
of the relationship between the
instrument that's being played in the
symphony and the actual individual like
vehicle that the instrument is being
played through the vehicle itself being
in peak shape makes it so that the
instrument is played in its peak
performance
simply and then this other point that
you mentioned think's really good is
this like it's this is so much about
skillful spirituality we've done some
episodes on it too and it's not just
about probably the most common way that
it's portrayed right now in this like
skillful spirituality way is that it's
not necessarily about you making an
influence on someone else and feeling
like you are responsible for making that
influence but rather it's something more
along the lines of being so skillful and
being so strategic that you're kind of
you yourself unconditional love
interconnectedness all the time and you
carrying that around as an aura makes it
so that other people can't they
themselves can't trigger you and then
they themselves see your peace and
tranquility in their mirror and they
realize [ __ ] I've just been yelling or
like being negative or or just maybe I
should respect the person that's sitting
there meditating why am i starting to
feel more calm and more at love but it's
also hard because our family members are
some of the people or our partners are
some of the people and our relationships
are the ones that business relationships
to that we think that it's our
responsibility to change to help them
see their worldview and stuff like that
and really it's by being our best we
catalyze the other person to be their
best and it's so hard with like
especially like a family member because
it may not even be this is really hard
to say but it may not even be in this
lifetime for them to learn the specific
lesson that they need to learn so not
only is it not you potentially but they
may go until 70 or 80 years of age and
die without ever learning that specific
lesson that they're supposed to learn
and that's just that's just the way that
life goes it may come up later for them
if they if that is how things work which
many people do this also I think
generationally
I mean our generation is pretty like at
least in this part of the world we grew
up in a peaceful environment and we're
not traumatized by Laird or trauma by
war and all that my grandparents they
experienced all that so their coping
mechanism throughout that period is
block out their whole emotional being so
they can survive through those severe
terrible things happened to them and so
for their lifetime
their mission is not to have spiritual
awakening their mission is to survive so
their offspring can hopefully have
another level of living and so I think
that's totally fine like if if I have no
expectation of my grandparents have any
changes because they've been through so
much for them to be able to provide for
us like I have nothing but gratitude
like yeah wow that's a great way to put
it too yeah and and but at the same time
my grandparents are changing too
beautifully and it was like grandpa has
dementia specifically but even like when
I go into the house before I would feel
really deeply sad and stressed for not
able to help him more to release his
mental pain or confusion but now I would
go in with like meditation music for
removing negative energy and it's crazy
the shift happens because grandpa would
be having his hallucination episode and
sometimes is really distressing so I
know that he's having a bad time but as
I'm playing these things slowly he will
calm down and I don't know if actually
it works like I don't know the
scientific study behind how he works or
if there is I think I can maybe take a
small guess at it which is that if they
themselves don't immediately get
triggered by you being at peace or
trying to play some thing to alter their
mood which sometimes they do and just
tell you to stop and then you're like
okay but if you just continue in the
state of peace and
that's not something that you can
technically stop but then what happens
usually at least physiologically that it
seems like is there something to do with
not only the orc and energetic states
but also on a physiological level
neurological level mirror neurons yeah
yeah safety decreases in cortisol
increases in oxytocin things like that
we're trying to understand it better but
I think those are some of the most like
bare-bones ways of trying to trying to
put it yeah yeah so I feel like even
then start shifting and now they express
more gratitude which never happened
before and it brings them joy brings me
joy and the relationship is start
shifting in a different way instead of
like blaming or complaining all the time
it's it's you know higher frequency of
vibration I think yeah yeah wow I feel
like so many people around the world
crave that next awakening for some of
their family members so it's actually
really important that you're talking
about it on the program and and it seems
like actually a lot of your acting and
modeling kind of like principles led you
to become any better human and a
spiritualist in the sense that you are
you're at play with the energies of your
family members in a more tactful yeah
it's definitely I think with acting also
reading all these stories you really
started learning different ways of lives
and and essentially almost all the
stories comes down to love and
communication so I think with a lot of
spirituality come to play is about
communicating better sharing sharing
that love better because we touched a
little bit of I was saying you were
telling me the concept of you believe to
God it was like embedding every one of
us and everything yeah and I was talking
my third like my therapist or not
my therapist my acupuncturist she was
talking about how consciousness
universal consciousness is kind of a
trickles down there's a logic behind it
and it's behind everything that we
create
it's from source or however you call it
but there is a intelligence behind it
and yes yes and we can we can like if we
each individually changes and heals and
we don't project and release negative
like not mindful like energy we know
that okay we it's not another person's
responsibility and we are not projecting
more negative things out there things
well butterfly shifts into a positive
place and there was hope that rotates
like if you want to heal the world to
heal yourself first and I really feel
that now like as I'm healing better the
things around me just getting better and
I really there was one point I asked my
therapist I was like well with my family
being like this with me choosing art
there while we always unstable like
drama and all these things happen how do
I get to peace and she's like that's
what you have less peaceful is not
really external is the internal so you
have to find your own value and how you
can be peace within the situation that
you are in because these things will
always be there so then that really
shifted is starting from like multiple
things but but I find okay internally
I'm shifting externally things still
happening but I'm coping better they're
shifting better everything start
shifting so I love it oh this is so
warming for my heart and I hope for
other people
this is something that's these nodes in
our social network are the closest to us
our family members our partners and our
relationships in our businesses
decisions so to to master this
skillfully is a deep process of self
work and in creating the divine and
healing through us and then also
realizing tactfully spirit spiritually
skillfully understanding how to engage
with those nodes around us to not have
unnecessary moments of suffering to
catalyze more moments of awakening love
this also on the plane while we were
flying you had honeysuckle okay I
thought this was so interesting when we
pulled this up because this is something
that I think has a lot to do with
evolution of consciousness of
spirituality which is that when you take
something that looks like you know
thousands or even tens of thousands of
years of lineage and history around
knowing how to engage with plants
medicinally knowing how to engage with
animals in a healing and therapeutic way
versus the killing millions of chickens
per hour for food and for treating
pharmaceuticals as the only solution for
for healing certain ailments of the body
when we looked up honeysuckle which is
something that you had with you that you
can pour into just the dry form into hot
water and stir it up and drink it and
that has thousands of years of lineage
of understanding of a healing properties
versus something that is when we look it
up on by do which is China's most
popular search engine that honeysuckle
comes up immediately with like
therapeutic properties and you're
looking at it and it's like plant
medicine style and on Google when you
look up honeysuckle it's uh it's a plant
and it also the only source of its like
buried the source of the medicinal
benefits and it's unlike WebMD
and even then it's not even that studied
studied or cared about it's like go look
at the pharmaceutical solutions for
these things instead of plants yeah it's
it well my mom is she's she's chief as a
physician in specialized de for kidney
but in in her hospital is combination of
Western medicine and Chinese traditional
herbal medicine yes and that's with her
within her practice that's the most
effective way and I think it's such a
shame that in the North American like in
the medical world
I think horrible medicine is not taking
seriously but like like I said the
honeysuckle is such a simple herbal
medicine and I had the flu and the next
day I was okay so it was so effective
compared to like any kind of flu
medication I can get it in the market
here but I don't know if you can
actually buy it here probably at some of
this most notable stores the path you're
teaching there of your mom does
specialist work in kidneys in the
hospital when when you say that the
focus is both with Western medicine
Eastern medicine what I think is a
holistic dwell thanks to mind holistic
plastic because otherwise it's just it's
just it's kind of like rationality and
intuition or science of spirituality all
these different ways of viewing the same
thing which is marrying these two to
make it so that you have a whole idea of
life reality healing medicine yeah a lot
of Chinese traditional medicine I think
is more about the healing from the root
so it's now symptom based it's more like
okay which part what what happened to
that part let's correct that part so
it's slower but Western medicine
suppress the symptoms so you are not
suffering as much and it's quick but
then does it heal
some are but yeah like I think a lot of
medicine we can get at the counter is
very symptom based for those flu a cold
or cough so the in those case I think it
would be interesting to explore more
holistic ways for for us for North
America yes absolutely and I want to ask
you a couple other quick thoughts on the
way out one of the questions is if you
think that we're all one yeah well like
undeniably I think we gave so much
labels and everything but come down to
it is all human ego and it's a way of
feeling superior or like it's
psychologically they have study right
once you label them into them and us
there is conflict and competition yeah
but it's just random study that where
they just labeled the same classroom of
people and there are all just people and
I think in society in the large-scale
and that's what we do it's like we label
them by countries or by race by religion
or by gender or whatever but come down
to it aware just people and same with
animals
yeah and plants like part of the earth
yes yeah yeah and my this thing that was
really beautiful she's like oh the
the originals like source is all love
yeah and we were born with a lot of
unconditional love yes I know how to
love and learn how to receive love we we
know how to receive love and that as a
social programming goes some of that we
are forgotten or being buried by fear
yeah so I think now we're just you know
a different social movement of learning
to UM program that fear recognize
certain fear is now serving us and or
not allowing the fear to control us and
just just go back to that loving state
hopefully yeah yeah that's such a vital
pillar of our next world yeah
having that unconditional love from
birth until death and a social fabric
that makes it so that it's yeah just
that is all that about the option is
there is no option for the fear and for
here is useful is a useful information
but not letting it control us right
we're just like a lot of marketing is
using fear and and it's always not
enough and everything so we just keep
consuming and feeling more holes but
this feel ours yes yes this creation
though has the exact recipe for being
most beautiful or challenging or
evolutionary or growth oriented because
there are those feelings of challenge
and pressure coming from the sides of
good and evil or whatever however you
want to view it we talked about good and
evil where I was talking about there's
an indigenous story of like the white
and black Gulf yeah yeah sure it and
they are fighting and then the kid asks
that the elder is like well the elder
was saying that it within us everybody
has a white and black wolf and always
fighting never killing each other but
the kid was like that how do we know
we're gonna win and then the elder said
whomever you feed so always feed I don't
like to say white and black wolf let's
just say light and dark light and darker
just always feed love feed love love so
whatever represents light and love the
harmony peace if we feed more into it
instead of the fear ego and anger so
that's that's something that next stage
I will practice is to because I was
recognizing accepting a lot of my
pattern that weren't serving me but
instead of keep talking about these
patterns I will put more my energy onto
the pattern that now I have accepted as
new programming that I know now how to
choose hopefully well it's well
constantly evolved but now I know what's
serving me better and hopefully I will
feed into those options more yeah I must
mention this that this whole idea of
going towards light and picking light
and all this type of stuff that it is
also deeply visible in the way that we
as a society are starting to call things
like light purity and people's skin
color people want to be more light they
want to marry people that are more light
they want their babies to be more light
so in a sense people of darker skin
tones are in a sense disadvantaged in
that in that sense and I think that's
also very interesting to think about is
if we label this light and darken and
feeding light as love then we see dark
or darker skin tone as something that
can again just this is a tough thing so
is there a way to maybe view a darker
skin tone as also love and feeding that
as love and then
you know maybe seeing sometimes a whiter
skin tone can be evil and we can see
that through many of the times in the
way that people are feeding their own
psychopathic egos at the top of
corporations and countries and wealth in
general conspicuous consumption all
these types of things and stomping on
the shoulders of other people on their
climbs up so I think that that could be
another interesting component to our
view on that yeah so let's not call it
two different colors since like since
we're right now in a sensitive time
period where colors of the skin plays so
much in politics and villainized in so
many ways or different conflicts around
the skin color let's just call it
fitting into the love more fitting to
the love of peace and harmony forces
havior of fear like distraction like
that okay so but it serves its purpose
in creation fear hate etc serves person
shouldn't take over shouldn't be the
drive for us and the more that we feel
the love and that clearly we anchor our
those feelings of love in our own
vehicular channel that is our body and
then it makes it so that we can Oracle
II bring forth that into our families
our communities our unique instrument
that's being played that's how that's
how it really deeply feels and I feel
really good I have one more question
what do you think is most beautiful wow
that's a huge question most beautiful I
think I love ya self love love between
people love between family friends
everything
love between the animals the things yeah
yeah I love that answer and the
breakdown no feel of it yet because
tapping into that is potentially one of
the most upstream things that we must
come together on and saw to solve all
the downstream issues yeah just a
thought like one of my girlfriend told
me this that she started spending 20
minutes a day telling each part of her
body how much she loved them and
appreciates them that's great I find
that was so refreshing because think
about how much especially now with
social media how much we do to compare
and say those negative things to do to
ourselves if we can reverse that yeah
and then how that are gonna affect other
people just look at the hands doing
everything for us and feet to eat yeah
feet in hands yeah yeah those two
specifically need lots of love cuz they
don't get it brain hard gut get lots of
love more so than hands and feet get
very very little yeah so then you know
being able to trip out on that love for
it is a crucial towards building that
great future so mmm-hmm hey this has
been so fun thank you so much Ellen
thanks for coming on the program thank
you this is so beautiful thank just met
two days before on the airplane yeah
yeah thank you for talking to me you're
so welcome
thanks very WorkSource has all these
ways of piecing together the puzzle
pieces to play in the symphony and yeah
yeah yeah that's how that's how this
totally feels I love it thanks everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking do have more
conversations to your friends families
coworkers
online about acting about directing
about modeling about spiritual awakening
about all the things that Faye was
teaching us on the program today
check out all four links in the bio
below as well go follow her on Instagram
her page is great go fall check out the
IMDB page also check out Poehler on
Netflix as well those links are in the
bio below and also support the artists
the entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
and your communities and around the
world support them help them grow you
can find all of our links to our show in
the bio below to our paypal patreon
cryptocurrency can design cool merch and
get paid all those links in the bio
below go and build the future everyone
manifest your dream since the world you
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon